merci d'être avec nous philippe Dominati
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élue de Paris à parenté au groupe
les républicains vous avez remis un
rapport sur la réforme de la police
judiciaire on va en parler dans quelques
minutes mais d'abord évidemment
l'actualité c'est la réforme des
retraites Elisabeth qui a donc maintenu
le cap hier sur France 2 elle a eu un
long exercice de pédagogie mais elle n'a
pas fléchi en tout cas sur les reports
de la Jet départ à 64 ans elle a fait
quelques ouvertures sur quelques points
mais elle maintient le cap alors que des
dizaines de milliers de Français des
centaines de milliers de Français
étaient dans la rue pendant deux
journées est-ce qu'elle a eu raison de
maintenir ce cap est-ce qu'elle ne donne
pas l'impression de ne pas écouter ce
que dit la rue elle a pas le choix elle
a pas le choix parce que c'est le
maintien pas le cap elle abandonne la
réforme réforme
dont on parle donc président de la
République parle depuis 2017
ça va occuper presque l'actualité de son
quinquennat vous vous souvenez qu'il y a
eu un haut commissaire chargé de cette
réforme qui est devenue ministre qui a
quitté le gouvernement il a mis dans le
programme présidentiel il avait annoncé
pour le mois de septembre puis pour le
10 décembre maintenant nous sommes le
premier février à chaque fois il y a des
adaptations plus ou moins réussie et en
réalité ça n'avance pas il est temps que
le pays passe à autre chose il n'y a pas
que cela dans le pays c'est un sujet
important mais il y a d'autres sujets
importants sur l'énergie sur
la vision de l'avenir de l'Europe les
menaces un certain nombre de choses et
donc à minima maintenant il faut avancer
donc si au Parlement d'agir et il faut
véritablement en finir il y a d'autres
choses d'autres sujets c'est très
important tous les présidents de la
République ont été confrontés à cette
réforme ils ont tous procédé parce qu'on
pourrait appeler la politique du salami
c'est-à-dire je prends je coupe une
petite tranche je fais une petite
réforme et je laisse le problème à mon
successeur et au gouvernement suivant
mais la réforme des retraites je dirais
il y en a une grande manifestation une
grande colère des Français par des
Scénic parce que c'est un problème
inéluctable on a un système qui n'est
pas financé les jeunes payent pour les
anciens et en réalité il y a plus assez
de jeunes pour payer pour les
générations les plus âgées donc en
maternelle on comprend ça alors après il
y a des adaptations soit vous baissez le
niveau des retraites soit effectivement
vous allonger la durée de vie à partir
du moment où vous avez le chance pour
les Français de vivre plus longtemps
est-ce que c'était le bon moment de
faire cette réforme on voit que sur le
fond vous la soutenez mais est-ce qu'il
y a pas un problème de calendrier
toujours un problème de calendrier mais
là on est au début d'un quinquennat je
veux dire ça a été dans le programme
présidentiel les syndicats dont on parle
en permanence représente quoi dans la
population française on sait très bien
on sait très bien qui essentiellement
ceux qui défilent c'est la fonction
publique comme il faut se dire des
choses moi je suis parisien j'ai vécu à
Paris c'est essentiellement à 80% la
fonction publique qui défile bon et ça
vous le voyez
le gouvernement favorise largement le
mode de retraite de la fonction publique
par rapport au reste de toute la
population active des gens s'indiqués
qui défilent vous avez vu des
manifestations dans des villes moyen
est-ce que vous avez pas l'impression
qu'il y a une colère défenseurs
le vrai sujet déjà de la réforme des
retraites que l'on devrait poser qu'on
n'a pas posé aux Français c'est ce que
le système paraît partition c'est-à-dire
d'une génération qui paye sur l'autre
c'est le bon système alors que tous les
pays développés pratiquement au monde
font le système par capitalisation
pourquoi on met pas le sujet sur la
table c'est ça le vrai sujet le problème
est de savoir si on n'aurait pas pu
mettre une dose de capitalisation ah oui
bien sûr ça se fait dans tous les pays
du monde il y a qu'en France où année
apprenait qu'un Canada après quinquennat
on protège contre l'adaptation
financière du système des retraites
parce qu'on n'arrive plus à le financer
si si on paye pas qui paye c'est le
contribuable c'est le même
prendre dans la poche droite ou dans la
poche droite gauche c'est ça le système
des retraites on va parler du fond et du
Parlement puisque vous le disiez
maintenant c'est au Parlement de décider
de ce que sera cette réforme ça arrive
lundi dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale on va en parler avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
à Mulhouse ou on retrouve Emmanuel de la
haie bonjour Emmanuel merci d'être avec
nous journaliste politique au journal
l'Alsace et au dernier nouvelle d'Alsace
et vous avez sondé vous Emmanuel les
députés alsaciens alors que le débat
commence l'indique comment ils abordent
ce débat parlementaire
alors pas tous pareils bonjour en fait
ils sont 15 en Alsace des députés il y
en a deux de la nupes un LFI et une
Europe Écologie légère dont on devine
qu'ils sont opposés à la réforme alors
on sait surtout intéressé au 13 autres
je vous avoue il y en a 11 à des titres
divers qui font partie de la majorité
présidentielle avec des étiquettes
diverses je veux dire et puis de
républicains des collègues de Monsieur
Dominati parmi les 11 de la majorité qui
sont naturellement les plus enclins à
voter cette réforme il y a aucun
automatisme pour autant ce ne sont pas
des députés godillot plusieurs m'ont
confié d'emblée qu'ils avaient été très
irrités par les propos de la première
ministre du week-end dernier quand elle
disait que le repas de l'âge légal à 64
ans n'était plus négociable ils l'ont vu
comme un affront fait au rôle même du
Parlement qui entend bien jouer tout son
rôle dans la dans le travail législatif
et donc pouvoir apporter Saint-Pierre à
l'édifice et amender le texte autour
duquel le débat vient de débuter
alors ils auront peut-être été adouci
par le ton plus conciliant de la
première ministre hier soir mais
n'empêche que encore une fois j'ai
insiste plusieurs ont été froissés par
ces propos très fermes de Liliane
semaine d'Elizabeth borne et puis quand
il parle d'amendement c'est pas juste
pour le plaisir il me disent qu'à leurs
yeux le texte actuel est encore
perfectible et ils sont soucieux de
l'améliorer sur des points comme la
pénibilité de certains métiers les
carrières longues les carrières au
contraire fractionnées des femmes en
raison des congés maternité la prise en
compte pourquoi pas du bénévolat ou du
statut des dents pour certains certaines
personnes qui peuvent aider des proches
malades enfin voilà ils entendent bien
pouvoir pleinement jouer leur rôle de
législateur au cours des deux semaines
qui s'ouvrent Didier Lemaire qui est
député horizon du Haut-Rhin me disait
sous un coup d'humeur s'il n'y a plus
rien à négocier et bien dans ce cas là
moi je n'exclut pas de voter contre dans
un même ordre d'idée son collègue du
Bas-Rhin 20 centièmes c'est pas
respectueux du Parlement tout simplement
et puis encore un autre exemple Bruno
Fuchs du modèle Ori noir député du
Haut-Rhin me disait pour l'instant je
suis dubitatif le gouvernement à mes
yeux s'y est mal pris en focalisant le
débat sur la question de l'âge de départ
là je l'égale de départ alors que mes
yeux le vrai critère c'est le nom de
d'années de cotisation enfin voilà voilà
leur état d'esprit je termine sur les
deux collègues républicains de Monsieur
Dominati il y a Patrick ketzel un
vétéran de l'Assemblée nationale et
alors lui c'est très simple il me dit
honnêtement je vais forger mon jugement
au cours des deux semaines qui viennent
en fonction des critères que je vous ai
cité lui aussi par exemple est
particulièrement sensible à la question
des petites retraites il y sera attentif
et déterminera son vote
sur ce point en grande partie mais pour
l'instant ils m'ont dit j'ai trois
boutons devant moi je sais pas encore
lequel j'utiliserai pour qu'on trouve
abstention et puis enfin le tout dernier
c'est Raphaël berger député du Haut-Rhin
lui il est très sceptique sur la volonté
de conciliation du gouvernement sur sa
volonté d'écoute et donc il se prépare
probablement à votre compte me dit-il et
du coup ma question à Monsieur Dominati
elle vient assez naturellement c'est ce
sont vos collègues républicains d'Alsace
alors certes ils sont députés ils ne
sont pas sénateurs mais ce sont malgré
tout vos collègues de parties est-ce que
vous comprenez leur réticence voir leur
irritation actuelle
là où tous les parlementaires de tous
les partis en Alsace semble avoir raison
c'est que le gouvernement a du mal à s'y
prendre pour communiquer pour expliquer
le sens de sa réforme et il m'a
l'aiderait ce politique que je crois que
c'est effectivement
tout le monde le ressent tous les
parlementaires le ressentent d'ailleurs
essayer de citer je mets au défi presque
n'importe quel français l'écart des
membres du gouvernement généralement au
bout de cinq ou six les citoyens ne
savent plus parce que ce gouvernement
n'incarne plus un gouvernement une
dirige plus le pays dans beaucoup de
ministères on ne sait pas qui incarne la
politique du gouvernement il y a cinq
chimistes reconnus et au-delà il y en a
35 qui sont inconnus ça c'est la
première chose pour mes collègues du
parti républicain
je sais pas
je sais simplement que il y a eu des
candidats dernières élections
présidentielles par ce parti par cette
mouvance politique et que il y avait un
projet à plusieurs reprises proclamaient
que ça a été dans le passé par François
Fillon ça a été par Valérie Pécresse
c'était un âge qui était 65 ans et au
Sénat chaque année nous avons voté
là où il y a une majorité de droite dans
les deux assemblées depuis chaque année
dans le budget social l'âge légal de 65
ans donc effectivement
en quelques mois ou en quelques semaines
on a le droit parce que les modalités
techniques ne sont pas bonnes c'est vrai
qu'il y a des cas particuliers qu'il
faut étudier et c'est le rôle du
Parlement mais sur le plan du programme
on sait très bien qu'on a financé
parce que la durée de vie s'allonge dans
notre pays des gens qui partent et qui
bénéficient d'une retraite pendant
beaucoup plus longtemps que lorsqu'on a
créé ce système
et que donc il a pas 36 solutions de
financiers soit vous baissez le niveau
des retraites et vous vivez mal et il y
a beaucoup de retraités qui vivent mal
parce que tout ça n'avait pas été prévu
il y a des carrières qui ont été
oubliées il y a des femmes qui n'ont
jamais été cotisées alors qu'elles
étaient femmes d'artisan ou femme de
commerçant elles n'ont pas prisé en
compte donc il faut rééquilibrer tout ça
mais c'est le système et c'est le rôle
du gouvernement de bien expliquer et de
moduler la réforme des retraites mais
mes collègues ils savent très bien qu'il
y a trois mois ils étaient pour 65 ans
alors justement cette maladresse du
gouvernement est-ce que vous la pensez
rattrapable ce qu'il a encore temps pour
le gouvernement de redresser la barre en
quelque sorte écoutez c'est pour ça que
je disais que si maintenant il n'avance
pas autant qu'il lâche prise et
peut-être que le Président il a le
pouvoir de dissolution c'est un très
fort si le gouvernement n'arrive plus à
gouverner
on appelle au peuple dans ces conditions
et un pouvoir de dissolution il est là
pour gouverner alors qu'il gouverne ou
qui rendent le pouvoir c'est tout mais
le problème du pays demeure le
financement demeure 3000 milliards de
dettes en 30 ans c'est une réalité moi
je veux bien qu'on aille à 4000 5000
donc je veux pas parce que je pense que
c'est des raisonnable et je pense à mes
enfants mais un moment donné il faut
quand même gérer j'ai juste un mot parce
que vos collègues républicains députés
ils ont déposé un amendement pour dire
que tous ceux qui ont travaillé qui ont
commencé à travailler avant 21 ans ils
doivent se voir appliquer les 43
annuités mais pas le report de l'âge
légal de départ à 64 ans vous pourriez
les suivre là-dessus oui je pense
qu'effectivement sur les le nombre de
trimestres à travailler mais c'est comme
les emplois c'est vrai qu'il y a des
emplois ou un certain âge vous ne pouvez
pas les exercer je veux dire
on peut pas faire un régime totalement
général mais il y a aussi des disparités
à gommer pourquoi pour la fonction
publique c'est les six derniers mois qui
comptent et pourquoi pour les autres
c'est la moyenne des 25 années de 25
dernières années
ok
régulièrement pour tout le monde un
équilibre pour tout le monde mais
pourquoi pour le secteur privé on ne
prend pas les 6 derniers mois de
retraite expliquez-moi pourquoi on le
prend pour les uns pas pour les autres
pourquoi il y a une capitalisation de la
retraite pour par exemple la fonction
publique et pas pour le secteur privé
moi je je suis dans le monde de
l'entreprise j'aimerais alors mettons
sur la table tout le monde
donc ça c'est la capacité du
gouvernement à convaincre à réguler et à
trouver le financement merci Emmanuel
Delahaye merci d'avoir été avec nous on
regarde vos deux une l'Alsace davantage
d'entreprise en difficulté en Alsace et
puis la Une des Dernières Nouvelles
d'Alsace l'école est encore trop
inégalitaire merci beaucoup Emmanuel
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin on va
passer à votre travail au Sénat puisque
vous avez remis un rapport il y a
quelques jours et on va voir le détail
avec
[Musique]
bonjour
et vous avez donc vu le rapport car du
Philippe de Minati sur les conséquences
que pour avoir la réforme de
l'organisation de la police nationale
sur la PJ quels sont les grands
enseignements alors Oriane avant de
commencer si vous me permettez je
voulais commencer justement par un cours
extrait d'interview nous sommes en
octobre dernier lors d'une manifestation
des enquêteurs de la police judiciaire
c'est extrêmement rare il faut le
souligner contre la réforme de la police
nationale voulue par Gérald Darmanin
écoutez la réforme de la police telle
qu'elle est envisagée à l'heure actuelle
surtout dans les dans les départements
j'en ai dans les antennes ça va ça va
créer
un déficit de
fonctionnaires sur des affaires de haute
importance tels que tout ce qui est
question de probité et pour l'instant il
y a que la police judiciaire qui peut
s'attaquer à ce genre de ce genre de
fluo et donc on est on est pas
heureusement contre cette réforme on
sent l'inquiétude une réforme qui
pourrait affaiblir la police judiciaire
et c'est en substance que dénonce votre
rapport un rapport que vous avez
commencé bien avant la polémique qui est
montée à l'automne avec on s'en souvient
le limoge d'ericarella le patron de la
PJ de Marseille en substance vous êtes
d'accord avec le ministre de l'Intérieur
il faut une réforme de la police
nationale qui travaille trop en silo qui
est trop cloisonné mais le gouvernement
ne s'y prend pas d'après vous de la
bonne manière pour comprendre il faut
d'abord savoir ce qu'est la police
judiciaire c'est les rivière pardon des
Brigades du Tigre tigre je vais y
arriver créé par George Clémenceau au
début du 20e pour traiter le haut du
spectre de la criminalité le crime
organisé le terrorisme plus largement
les crimes les plus graves et les plus
complexes elle intervenir et c'est très
important sur un large spectre
géographique elle a pour cela des moyens
dédiés qui ne sont pas superflus est-ce
que vous soulignez et elle obtient des
résultats probants 74% des lucidations
contre les contrefaçons 95% pour les
affaires de trafic de stupéfiant bref ça
fonctionne avec la réforme l'APJ serait
comme tous les autres services de la
police départementalisés et placés sous
l'autorité d'un préfet ce qui provoque
deux inquiétudes relevées dans votre
rapport la crainte comprenne les moyens
de la police judiciaire pour aider à
résoudre les plus petits délits et le
cloisonnement trop pétriqué de la PJ à
l'échelle du département alors que le
crime organisé ce mondialise et se
complexifie ce sont vos termes en clair
philippe Dominati est-ce que le
gouvernement doit revoir sa copie oui
sur ce volet là de la réforme il doit
revoir sa copie je pense que d'ailleurs
le ministre en a pris conscience
puisqu'il est là plutôt
procédé une sorte de phase de transition
à un moratoire sur ce volet là il a
reculé d'ailleurs moi je fais un rapport
il a reculé le calendrier il attendait
moi je vous fais un rapport pour la
commission des finances qui a duré assez
longtemps parce qu'on était interrompu
par la crise du covid
ce qui est vrai c'est que dans le budget
rien n'est prévu 2023 ça devait être
appliqué en 2023
est-ce qu'on crée un échelon
supplémentaire dans le département et ça
améliore l'efficacité au contraire
est-ce qu'on complique la hiérarchie en
tout cas le rapport pour la commission
des finances c'est simple c'est est-ce
que ces services a les moyens de bien
fonctionner oui est-ce qu'il fonctionne
bien oui est-ce que la réforme l'impact
oui donc je détaille les services est-ce
qu'une réforme de la police nationale
est nécessaire elle est plus que
nécessaire parce que il y a un
éclatement
manque de
coordination je dirais entre les
services
mais la départementalisation de l'action
de la police judiciaire et préjudiciable
ce qu'il y a de vrai et le ministre
comme la direction générale de la police
ont raison parce que la police
judiciaire est trop cantonnée dans le
haut du spectre c'est-à-dire que elle
traite assez peu d'affaires elle traite
des affaires les plus importantes mais
assez peu d'affaires par rapport à tous
les délits et à tous les crimes qu'il y
a ça veut dire qu'il faut pas supprimer
cette réforme de la police judiciaire il
faut revoir la copie il faut revoir la
copie bien sûr c'est le sens du rapport
au Sénat on essaie de faire avancer les
choses donc on dit
globalement il faut une réforme mais là
ça colle pas et ça colle pas à cause
essentiellement de l'organisation
administrative de nos pays quelle est la
départementalisation les bassins de
criminalité dépassent largement le cadre
du département nous avons fait à des
agents de l'État qui sont des
spécialistes des spécialistes dans
la technologie
la criminalité de plus en plus forte par
la technologie il y a une
course-poursuite je dirais entre les
criminels et les policiers pour la
technologie il y a des bassins le côté
international ça peut à peu près 20 à
25% de la criminalité en France elle est
internationale elle est pas cantonnée
dans un département or la hiérarchie ce
qu'on appelle la police en silo jusqu'à
présent on dépendait de l'Office Central
je suis un agent qui fait un métier
difficile dans le domaine de la drogue
dans la criminalité financière dans la
cybercriminalité je dépends devant un
office central là la crainte c'est que
je vais dépendre d'un directeur
départemental qui va me noter qui va me
payer je dépendrai de ma hiérarchie et
lorsque en haut on voudra dire mais il
faudrait aller dans les départements
voisins ou infiltré tel groupe ou tel
zone géographique la tentation sera
forte
pour les patrons du département de dire
bah oui mais avant vous allez me traiter
les délits moindres il y a une
différence entre le vol d'une tondeuse à
gazon et le braquage d'une banque et
donc on ne peut pas mélanger alors on
dit il y a trop de d'augmentation de la
criminalité et on va demander à ces
agents spécialistes de faire la police
judiciaire pour aider la voie publique
qui engorgée on peut prendre des
chirurgiens pour soigner des grippes on
a le droit ce sont des médecins mais il
vaut mieux qu'il fasse je dirais le
métier pour lequel ils ont été formés
ils ont travaillé ce sont pas les mêmes
horaires il y a beaucoup de choses qui
vont pas et donc nous on dit simplement
et raisonnablement au Sénat au ministre
sur ce sujet on n'est pas tout à fait
d'accord
sur ce sujet vous craignez que la PJ
fasse les frais de la concurrence au
sein des différents services de police
on apprend par exemple dans votre
rapport que les membres de la police
judiciaire sont surnommés les seigneurs
de la PJ et qui pourraient en pâtir
finalement de cette concurrence entre
les services oui c'est vrai je dirais on
sent la confrontation entre différents
services dans dans le rapport que je
fais j'ai constaté je suis allé sur
place j'ai rencontré beaucoup de monde
on sent que pour certains ce sont les
seigneurs d'autres les nantis on dirait
ils prennent les affaires qui veulent
ils participent pas et ils sont pas dans
le cadre de la hiérarchie mais c'est
leur méthode de fonctionner depuis
presque un siècle je dirais une sorte
d'indépendance et l'Ukraine
l'indépendance à l'arménisterie de les
rassurer en disant ben sur
l'indépendance vous n'aurez pas à faire
ceci vous n'aurez pas faire cela mais
c'est une réforme qui n'est pas très
originale parce qu'elle ressemble trop à
le jacobinisme de l'administration
française on crée un échelon
supplémentaire où sont les bureaux quels
moyens on va mettre pour les électeurs
départementales de la police j'ai visité
plusieurs départements les services sont
éclatés entre la police judiciaire qui a
3 km la sécurité publique la PAF elle
est directeurs disent mais est-ce que
vous allez me donner monsieur le
sénateur un bâtiment pour regrouper tous
les services dans ce bâtiment je n'ai
même pas la place pour les bureaux on
peut rêver d'une police idéale mais
d'abord l'état doit mettre les moyens
rien n'est prévu lorsqu'on vous vendez
prévisions financières on en a aucune un
dernier justement l'a entendu
témoignages que j'ai que j'ai diffusé
tout à l'heure vous parlez aussi d'un
manque de concertation avec les agents
sur le terrain et d'une réforme qui n'a
pas su convaincre les services concernés
ben oui parce que alors c'est d'autant
plus extraordinaire que le directeur
général de la police c'est un homme
reconnu et qui vient de la police
judiciaire et donc il connaît son métier
c'est incontestable j'ai connu moins
trois directeurs de la police lui il est
vraiment du métier bon
il fait partie de ceux qui critiquent le
plus la réforme il a essayé de
d'adapter cette réforme nécessaire de la
police par la départementalisation c'est
pas la bonne échelle géographique encore
une fois sur ce côté là ça ne fonctionne
pas et puis deuxièmement on se pose la
question du préfet
en réalité est-ce qu'on essaye de
décharger le préfet d'un certain nombre
de fonctions où on essaye de trouver un
fusible entre le préfet et les services
de police parce que actuellement dans le
métier de préfet presque un tiers ou 40
% de l'activité quotidienne journalière
d'un préfet c'est la sécurité publique
c'est l'immigration c'est la drogue
c'est un certain nombre de choses et
c'est vrai que le préfet il a en face de
lui souvent une seule personne qui
incarne la gendarmerie et plusieurs
personnes qui incarnent la police donc
mais dans le département ça va se jouer
comment alors là c'est un service qui
est vraiment
transfrontalier j'allais dire parce que
ça concerne des zones régionales il y a
eu des zones régionales récentes
on a même pas encore le retour
d'expérience merci au
Drey parler de réforme des retraites
[Musique]
historique est un peu surprise
finalement sur l'IVG le Sénat qui a
inscrit dans la Constitution la liberté
de recourir à l'IVG la majorité de
droites dans sa majorité n'y était pas
favorable et c'est pourtant un
amendement du sénateur les républicains
Philippa qui a trouvé le consensus dans
l'hémicycle vous l'avez voté cet
amendement alors que vous étiez abstenu
lors de l'examen précédent du texte
parce que pourquoi parce que la
formulation de Philippa était meilleur
que le précédent texte
oui bien incompréhension il y a
plusieurs thèses sur ce sujet d'abord un
certain nombre de collègues disent il
faut pas toucher la Constitution pour
tous les sujets parce qu'on va pas en
sortir ils peuvent avoir raison moi
parce que je suis rentré au Sénat je
modifié à cette reprise j'étais convoqué
à cette reprise à Versailles en quatre
ans par deux présidents de la République
de droite pour des modifications de
constitution parfois touchant sur
l'environnement donc
pour moi c'est un argument qui n'est pas
nécessairement le plus probant bon alors
après il y a la compréhension et la
compréhension c'est que pour beaucoup de
personnes ça semblait être une remise en
cause de la loi règne et ça moi je ne
sais pas partisan et je n'ai pas cette
lecture du texte alors évidemment il y a
une subtilité politique
présenté par l'opposition prenant
prétexte du débat qui a eu lieu aux
États-Unis alors que c'est pas un sujet
franco-français il y a pas de danger en
France mais cette incompréhension qui
est qui semblait dire que le cheyna
entre guillemets un peu ringard aller
remettre en cause
l'existence de l'application de la
loiveille pour moi ce n'était pas en
tout cas mon choix politique donc
lorsque la première fois ça a été
présenté au Sénat je me suis abstenu
entre je dirais ces différentes visions
les uns sur la constitution les autres
sur la religion cause le troisième sur
l'internationalisation du débat là
maintenant de Philippe Bas me convenait
parce qu'il mettait les choses au point
et c'est pour cela que je l'ai voté et
que finalement il a convaincu un grand
nombre de collègues de la droite de le
vote il nous reste une minute on va
parler de Paris et de ce qui vous agace
un petit peu c'est la question des
trottinettes puisque Anne Hidalgo veut
une votation sur cette question des
trottinette début avril papa vous
d'abord je trouve ça cocasse parce que
Madame Hidalgo pourrait poser plein de
questions aux Parisiens sur la propreté
de Paris sur le fait de son engagement
de pas avoir augmenté les impôts locaux
les augmenter laver si tu es engagé pas
se présenter au présidentiel la seule
chose qu'elle ait trouvé c'est la
trottinette on se demande à quoi elle
sert en termes de légitimité parce que
si la mère de Paris a perdu tellement sa
légitimité qu'elle ne peut même plus
arbitrer entre les vélos et les
trottinettes en ce moment vraiment à
quoi il servent donc c'est déjà l'objet
même du sujet c'est dans l'indifférence
presque la plus totale deuxièmement
symboliquement ça m'amuse parce que le
premier cadeau qu'on fait un enfant
c'est une trottinette alors c'est c'est
bien on va interdire les jets privés on
va interdire les trottinettes on va
interdire beaucoup de choses l'interdit
c'est la règle actuellement souvent de
la gauche d'interdire j'interdire des
terrasses chauffés etc donc c'est une
ambiance un peu étonnante troisièmement
moi j'utilise les trottinettes et je
suis pour les trottinettes alors il y a
on va commencer par la trottinette on va
interdire après les vélos après les
scooters et les livreurs et puis après
les motos après les voitures elles
prennent les taxis après les poids
lourds donc c'est de placer les uns
contre les autres alors évidemment c'est
mal géré les trottinettes chaudes tout
de suite il y en a par terre il y en a
partout il y en a sur les trottoirs et
roule n'importe comment mais là c'est
pas les fautes des utilisateurs des
trottinettes c'est la faute de la police
municipale qui n'est pas présente qui
est pas là qui est pas là mais quelle
interroge sur la propreté de Paris ça
vaudrait la peine mais sur les
trottinettes c'est tout ce qu'on a
trouvé donc ça m'amuse quoi
c'est pas très amusant mais c'est un
problème
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
dans 20 minutes dans le club du
territoire vous l'avez compris on
reparlera de la réforme des retraites
opération pédagogiques d'Elizabeth
borgner soir alors peut-elle encore
convaincre ce sera la question et on va
en parler tout de suite avec notre
prochaine invité c'est la député la
France insoumise Aurélie trouvée qui
nous rejoint très bien merci bonne
journée